[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs a vite vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi
13 juin après les mamans c'est tout dit
papa de recevoir leurs colliers de pâtes
nous vous donnons une idée de cadeau
originale et facile à réaliser
le club de modélisme de mort paille
quinquagénaire pour fêter cela une
journée spéciale est organisée ce
dimanche nous retraçons de l'histoire du
club avec son actuel président
l'association pour promouvoir la musique
classique de saint quentin en yvelines
vous conduit à son traditionnel opéra
des enfants
cela se passe au théâtre national ce
samedi 15 juin ils vous présenteront
pinocchio ce dimanche 17 juin c'est la
fête des pères pour l'occasion notre
créatrice évinoise elena gielen nous
apprend à réaliser des cactus en origami
avec lous la raal by adrien c'est une
équipe de choc qui est lena a réuni nom
de l'opération fête des pères c'est un
petit cactus en pot comme ça tout simple
avec plusieurs techniques d'origami
première partie fit le pot de bandes de
papier de couleur sont nécessaires l'une
de six centimètres par 5 et l'autre de 2
cm par 18 premières astuces de l'ema se
servir de la table pour arrondir sa
bande de papier avant de le scotcher
pour former son pot la deuxième bande
vient ensuite faire le aux étapes
suivantes
le cactus avec une vente 29 cm par 7 5
donc on va faire un accordéon s'est
passée la file conflit dans un sens puis
dans l'autre
attention à être méticuleux et bien
aligné les piles sûrs maintenant que
vous avez ce papier en accordéon vous
voyez on va réaliser ces petits plis en
zigzag
on va se mettre à à peu près à un
centimètre et demi du haut et vous allez
plier comme si vous allez reculé de 1 cm
à peu près encore
vous obtenez des petits carrés sur
lesquels il faut tracer des diagonales à
l'aide d'une règle et d'un crayon
elles serviront de repères pour le
pliage et alors il va falloir plié en
zigzag sur chacun des traits que vous
avez fait de façon à ce que ça dessine
des dents de requins ne pas hésiter à
bien marquer le pli avec lungs ensuite
on replie l'accordéon
donc on alterne le long du zig zag que
l'on a créé avec les pluies ont fait
leur entrée les prix intérieurs ne reste
plus qu'à développer fixé son cactus et
l'empoter vous pouvez même ajouter une
fleur en décoration
[Musique]
1969 des passionnés de modélisme de
modélisme créer leur cloud à maurepas
cinquante ans après il est toujours
actif et compte 130 adhérents
thiery dano vous en à être le président
bonjour bonjour alors 50 ans séparée 1
on va retracer un peu son histoire donc
tout d'abord comment il est né ce club
donc le club est né en 1969 là où vous
l'avez dit alors il a commencé par faire
2-2 du vol circulaire en avions fait le
vol circulaire c'est un avion au bout
d'une ficelle avec un petit moteur qui
vous tournez vous tournez votre mémoire
d'où le nom vols circulaires et puis la
technologie a évolué et la radiocommande
est arrivé ce qui a permis de faire de
libérer un peu le côté circulaire est
passé à des avions radiocommandés donc
en 83 84 les premières à de commandes
les premiers avions qui vont commencer à
voler de manière cycle et le club en
fête premier nom du club c'est là est ce
qu y pour l'association aéromodélisme de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qu'il faut
savoir et l'anecdote du club qui est
intéressant c'est que le mille club où
on est installé aujourd'hui a été
construit par les adhérents en 1970 en
fait 72 maintenant même les adhérents
ont construit on leur a mis à
disposition tous les matériaux et les
adhérents ont mis en place tous les tous
les éléments ou construits chose
inconcevable aujourd'hui donc c'est
aussi un club qui s'est adaptée aux
évolutions l'a dit au début il y avait
de l'aéronautisme aujourd'hui ça a
disparu dans les années 2000 je crois
qu'il ya plus de la voiture donc pour
être plus précis voilà donc en fait
cette activité-là faut savoir que le
club de modélisme en pas été
historiquement très proche de la ville
et les unit nuisances sonores dues au
bruit des petits moteurs thermiques qui
équipent les avions en fait gêner les
voisins est en fait la partie
aéronautique a disparu dans les années
90 et donc à partir de 88 notre activité
a commencé à apparaître qui est la
voiture à de commandes et qui fait moins
de bruit kimball - qui fait moins de
bruit sur la partie supérieure
ça fait du bruit au sol et d'autres
activités
dans les locaux qu'on avait qui sont ce
qu'on appelle le circuit routier plus
connu sous le nom de scalextric sous
carrera que les enfants connaissent
parfaitement
mais là c'est des grands enfants qui
jouent des enfants qui vont de 7
finalement à 77 ans on a beaucoup de
retraités qu'ils adorent ces loisirs en
fête et que le club s'est beaucoup de
courses et je crois que vous avez des
anecdotes avec les commentateurs de ses
courses
alors oui ou non une très belle anecdote
on a même quelques photos encore donc
tout le monde connaît danièle gilbert
qui était présentatrice vedette à la
télévision française
il va un jour elle est venue en 1989
elle est venue commenter une course qu
avait lieu encore sur un parking parce
que c'était des courses de ce qu'on
appelle les voitures de piste qui
roulait sur du bitume donc les courses
se faisait sur des parkings et donc on
avait une présentatrice vedette qui
était danièle gilbert
vous parlez de cours sur des parkings
aujourd'hui vous avez de sacrées
infrastructures dans ce club
donc oui on a beaucoup évolué en fait
aujourd'hui on s'est spécialisé en fait
sur la partie voitures radiocommandées à
l'échelle 1 8e on a une piste tout
terrain qui était historiquement dans la
ville de maurepas et qu'on a déplacé en
2011 dans la zone paris ouest derrière
gilles aubin royal qui de là on a une
vraie infrastructures 3000 mètres carrés
une piste avec 250 mètres de développé
et qui permet de faire évoluer
tranquillement les voitures le 6 jours
sur 7 du lundi au samedi de 12h à 19h
donc aujourd'hui c'est vous le président
depuis dix ans même c'est ça comment
vous êtes arrivé dans ce club
comment vient cette passion du modélisme
la passion du modélisme cesser ses
tresses historiquement j'ai commencé le
modélisme voitures radiocommandées en
1984 j'avais 16 ans et j'ai acheté une
voiture d'occasion parce que j'avais pas
les moyens quand on est jeune on n'a pas
forcément les moyens
et puis pendant longtemps j'ai fait ça
dans les bois comme beaucoup de gens
dans les parkings et puis j'ai eu des
enfants
les enfants ont grandi et puis c'est eux
qui m'ont entraînée en fait on a été
inscrit au club de morte en 2002 avec
mes enfants
et puis finalement le fil en aiguille je
suis entré au bureau de l'association
avec un rôle de deux spécialistes d'une
section et puis au fur à mesure voilà
donc l'opportunité un jour s'est
présenté au chercher un président et
puis
doigts pour pouvoir apprendre la place
et puis finalement ça s'est bien fait et
on a fait des choses fantastiques tous
ensemble ce dimanche l'anniversaire que
vous fêtez rapidement on arrive à la fin
de l'entretien cet entretien qu'est ce
qui se passe dimanche donc dimanche on
voulait fêter dignement les 50 ans du
club donc on a deux courses d'organiser
une course officielle du championnat
régional avec des voitures électriques
pas forcément beaucoup d'inscrits parce
que c'est une activité qui commence à se
développer et les pilotes sont pas
encore très nombreux
on a mis en place pour le club pour les
pilotes du club eu ce qu'on appelle une
amicale dire qu'ils puissent s'entraîner
voir ce que c'est qu'une compétition
pour s'entraîner et on a mis deux
activités à destination du public qu'on
était une activité slot racing dire pour
venir vous entraînez faire des temps
chrono et vous amuser et une deuxième
activité de voitures radio commandées
pour voir ce que c'est à l'échelle ce
qu'on appelle un 28e des voitures qui
font dix centimètres qui évoluent sur
une moquette pour voir et pour
s'entraîner ouvert à tout le monde
gratuitement
venez en profiter on va conclure sur ces
jolis mots n'ont cessé dimanche
keller ça commence les animations vont
commencer vers 10 heures
la course va commenter va commencer
d'art 9h à peu près et jusqu'à 18h le
soir
donc vous pouvez retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site internet
la verrière se lance dans la course
alors pas de modélisme met à pied
ce samedi 15 juin c'est la toute
première édition de la verrière 'on de
cours de 4 5 km et 9 km départ 9 heures
et un rallye famille départ 10h 45
rendez vous sur la pelouse du scarabée
plus aquatique le championnat régional
de kayak-polo vivent ils s'affronteront
au centre nautique de l'île de loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines ce dimanche
16 juin de 9h30 à 16h n'hésitez pas à
venir encourager trappe
nos représentants évinois de la
compétition les yeux pleins d'étoilés ce
festival de cinéma jeune public dont on
vous parle dans notre brique dans les
salles
[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa rond cette fin
d'année scolaire on va essayer de faire
se rassembler les familles autour du
cinéma et dans cette salle de cinéma
avec le festival les yeux pleins
d'étoilés sa neuvième édition et on
souhaite que les gens viennent passer
des bons moments en famille avec leurs
enfants entre grands-parents et
petits-enfants dans cette salle de
cinéma pour partager et construire des
souvenirs ensemble
alors on va avoir une soirée ciné
frisson qui s'adresse plus évidemment
aux adolescents et aux gens qui aiment
le cinéma d'horreur avec puff et prince
des ténèbres mais on va aussi avoir du
cinéma de patrimoine avec cyrano de
bergerac
on va aussi avoir des films des vraies
comédies comme le retour du héros de
laurent tirard avec dujardin et mélanie
thierry qu'on a passés ont déjà cette
année mais qui est tellement drôle qu'on
avait envie de leur montrer le roi et
l'oiseau grand film de cinéma
d'animation français
un mythe ce film qu'on vous invite à
venir découvrir ou redécouvrir une salle
de cinéma c'est toujours une expérience
formidable
et puis
on va rediffuser des films qui ont été
passés dans le cadre de école et cinéma
dans le département cette année
le garçon est le monde et la petite
vendeuse de soleil un film sénégalais
deux petites merveilles que les enfants
dans les écoles ont découvert cette
année et qu'on invite à venir découvrir
avec leur famille avec leurs parents à
faire découvrir ce film un spectacle sur
la compagne de victor hugo dans le parc
de la maison de famille où a vécu les
fans et victor hugo avant de jouer dans
le cadre du festival off d'avignon le
spectacle juillet tour et offre une
représentation exceptionnelle en plein
air dans cette maison de fourqueux ce
vendredi 14 juin à 21h avant d'être
palmé à cannes le réalisateur jerry
schatzberg était photographe de mode
pour des magazines comme vogue ou
cosmopolitan le château du domaine de
chamarande lui consacre une
rétrospective reportage de yamina
benguigui da de nos confrères via grand
paris fidel castro prise en photo
quelques minutes avant sa prise de
pouvoir
catherine deneuve saisis chez son
coiffeur à l'âge de 16 ans diana ross
en plat mouvements de danse dans une
boîte de nuit ou encore les rolling
stones supposé être habillés comme leur
mère autant de clichés saisis par le
célèbre photographe jerry schatzberg
sont exposées dans le château de
chamarande en essonne vous pouvez
apercevoir ma façon de penser
je peux être joyeux je peux être cynique
vous savez vous pouvez voir quelque
chose sur mes photographies et moi je
verrais autre chose à 15 cm
je ne peux pas vous dire ce que vous
devez observer je veux dire quand je
vois une femme assise près d'une
boutique avec un serpent dans la main
c'est simplement une partie de ce que je
vois dans la rue boîte
je prends des photos pour que les gens
puissent s'y voir ce qu'ils veulent y
voir
je ne prends pas de photographier pour
moi la spontanéité et l'imprévu sont les
maîtres mots du photographe âgé de 91
ans pour lui prendre des photographies
c'est raconter la vie la vérité
la plupart du temps je cherche à montrer
la vérité c'est ma priorité
et lorsqu'on demande à l'artiste quelles
sont ses sources d'inspiration robbins
fait marcher dans la rue lire des livres
faire l'amour regarder la télévision
tous les moments de la vie j'ai 91 ans
et la vie est une véritable source
d'inspiration de l'artiste se lance dans
une carrière de cinéaste en 1969 alors
âgé de 40 ans il sera par exemple à
l'origine des films
portrait d'une enfant déchue besoin
d'amour ou encore la vie privée d'un
sénateur au grand concours c'est le nom
de l'exposition de jerry schatzberg est
visible jusqu'au 1er septembre
et c'est la fin de votre circuit choisir
bonne fête à tous les papas et plus
particulièrement aux miens rendez vous
jeudi prochain pour de nouvelles idées
sorties
[Musique]
ouais
oh
[Musique]